l'one a stick on my name and sapri al
franchi a the next station creation of
physiology grande spicco di lorenzo
mariani tm news
il vecchione professes magnani hans tired
of the best of influence Italians a
[Music]
professions in which george logic science
and stephanie  black box technology
technology
the stars and outlets a blatter fa
commission of upstream and logic the ancient
as to the powers cold ironing facebook a
bonn kraft title understanding violence
and wine inaugural tv balls gen and
violence african states of 20
professes the hands of others
prejudice main course
thank you for organ this wonderful
interdisciplinari series of conference
betis very very interesting and higher
honor had to be one of people that will
present something about inference is
life from the perspectives models and of
course
thanks bear to all the people that in
this  moment attending mai presentation
ok only the title now presentation
have you can't see is art scientific
mod  els fictions hands up title model
based science and epistemica warfare are
ai uil di mai mai presentation in frame
parts the first one is
about the relationship that there is
beat ween abduction and models the
second heart will be devote da tu e con
section of models and  distributed end in
dissenso we can't say they were nota
strat di so uno dire hughes valeee
wen speaking about model singh sayan sui
sei dei a they are abstract or they are
ahead e alize but i will contende bear
always con cruz objects and that it  is
but to treat then he script object della
start again fiction al islam ok saw the
first part is concerning abduction nel
models first o gol prelim e preliminari
slight scientific models are now not
only consider ed el youssef always
forest plaining faz or discovery new
enty slot  in floris but are also
rubricate under barrios new labels
front classical once
you have a liu income for the usual areas the
black label heads up struct and by the
eyes to th  e more recent vision pro
magical nights shaun credible words music
systems surrogates models
so when i'm younger that is about sotto
6 thirty years ago and also be nice
started the series of international
conferences with together with the ex
leader sessi en el portal guard  cold
model based reasoning conférences del
closing night in nitegate models were
killed in philosophical and peace
tecnology al film just models di torno
presente theory o models fictions models
and make believe enzo and the
proceedings of the conference web devote
base cali to describe illustrator the
role of  the role of others in science
and models and has ideal session das
traction aro and pervasive permanent
feature of science bof in normal entry
bucciano revolutionary processes in my
opinion is fundamental in central role
playing time or jersey science il the one
wi fi in color confetto al  discovery
processes that are constitutive omnium
sentivi frameworks ennio empirica aldo
makes esi 1 these  are some i jumpers o
smolders hatches insor mechanix learn
about oscillations ma investigati in the
dynamic ad properties of the so called
ideal pentolone del nord waters of
sanctifies models and pendolum
del Consiglio ove nextreme shaun les
pendulum
baghdatis spende brom and pivot or in
masters and perfectly  linear string popul
e shawn biology ststa di devolution
albans pisis the three produces ed
constant threat in e nun ce jing'an
dall'istat in b exchange group economist
consider the situation i due
claire are only to roots tour acciona la
gens norek strip non hai  labor
information or transaction cost money
and the links ardone in media 3 su you see
that we re di wind business simple
images and description softball de
suisse beth models are some thing
abstract ai dal eyes hands on any way
keep your mind disks vai via concerning
models  and especially the fact that we
consider models scientific models very
important in scientific process because
models are c  rucial wen scientist are
looking for santi new and disease and
image of the hindu lou and this is the
population image of population biology
da tarde standard e samp horse carding
scientific models in science
ok when you speak about abduction that
was born inventa e mai aristotle
aristotle  colleagues abduction a pago gay
and recovery and arrested
by charles under spurs kinds of you know
of dust bybee arnott how many tweed
concept ora silent
beh abduction represents all kinds of
reason into a hypotesis bot creative and
selected so when you in vetta più di
screen to know  the king distinction
between discovery and invention because
i'm not committed to and warm metaphysical
realism per tirar discovery in
something that honor of exist wen in
dissenso disease devote to the
philosopher Dettar presents aim post
canti am not 3 cantiano ok the new wave
action is  description of all the reason
is that happens when you are making il
new l'potesi sbat also when you are
maki  ng diagnose his way you are to
select among encyclopedia of horror and
comings and goings napoli can thesis doctor house is
making abductions enzo sherlock holmes
but also kechler wendy's covered disease
di example of charles hunger spurs
wendy's cover ed elite tikal orbit of
planet e liu kang siderar two  men types
of adaptive cognition one sententia that
is a man lee fundamental youtube
of natural language ora of symbolic
languages like logic and model based it is
one discovering the event of model
sto e model based abduction is enoug
selective betis diagnostic or creat
ve zen tex en vente  models are you
see e model that is not it is not use
the typical example of mouth scientific
models but it is e inter è stick not
because it is e euclid il gran that was
built by nicolai ivanovich lobacevske i
to discover per first non  uk lillian
geometries and it is important because
it is thanks to this model that
lobacevske he is able to get into and ride
to the discovery of the so  called a
hyperbolic non uk lillian geometri ok so
when we are speaking of water best
cognition
it is it is god of war charles hunter
spurs di cosa il to to heaven and good
eye via out and roll hall of what else
in cognition general noto non in  science
we have to remember the first step said
allstor thinking easing science e sahin
change icons in this is war symbols
moreover holt inference isaf form of
science tvt where the world shining
cluses disarm wurtz directly bikers
feeling image conception in the sense of
concept and other representation  ending
song words all synthetic forum of
gleision decided considerable part of the
thinking attivit ismo del best of course
model based reasoning a wired.it
peculiar created short but on and shuttles in
suitable next so this is a tucson
maryse in other words divisa e
philosophical suggestion  that when we
are making inference is with un hotel to
consider inference only medi using wars
ora artificial symbolic languages bu  t
also feeling bear feeling bear emotion
images that is models and other
representation
this is important and here you have e
liszt all kinds of model based rigori
sono in pet are not only active in
science but also been are other r area
slow fiom also united for  instance
hanika indoor simulativa reasoning for
instance hughes i computers analogy
visura iconic reasoning sfasciate in
team toth esterno e tis fra mousse depot
experiment galileo about the falling
botis de teaser the birth of modern
science perceptions of perception d'iseo
last e canto
del rest gleision visori  ma geri bear
integrated taken in we can find aspect o
model based asp ex bad guys risone
paradoxical hi end bear ice at the role
of e motion emotion following for saturday
all sorrise incognite scientist is e
kind of cognition of course north
necessary correct but it is  the kind of
vision by the way bear abduction is
reasoning data un explosive la
hypotesis death letter with ken b
consider  a lo show the best spa national
for instance in science bat è yes un no i
polli in science usuali best esplana
chance artemporary temporary beagles you
can have you can have la s thomas kuhn
karl popper and her ad philosophy of
science set revolution senso newco and
is easy in general typical of abducted
cognition when you ricci e brest
explanation disease nor month sterile
permanent because you can change it
also il diagnostic risoli ok you see the
torso in everyday life and read and life
of human beings there are model based
objects shapes and  science in the way
and for instance del models of
abstract object of chess su cui are full
of model based aspect in science
we also have the kind of manipolativa
traction ai cold manipolativa abduction
eric idle abduction vectis per ford buy
e manipulation of external artifacts
closed in  this case we have artists of
museum
ma university and for instance dei magic
the rights israel quarti fax used by
alessandro volta vec  chi un perfectly non
louise alexandro volta
and what is the important that we are
turtù grasp that some of these artifact
a artifact bear invensense models of
that the great models
by the way you have also to consider
that also Disegno credi andai a kram is
hell artifact  of course it is not e
marty lay forces nob jazz o via
alessandro volta mathijsen artifact
because it is a concrete ok song and
this point
we have to deal with problem notes è il
90 a casa la quick web access pria a un
menù blake abduction experiment  to
sell off
ok boot fashion week end henrich mai
description mani più la tve abduction is
not refer two experiments shaun di cosa
hai forgot to say that it a e tease kind
of activity relate to think in orchards
is it is not like id casey shaw rites or
experimentation  e kind of grand prix
process su you clan to mac in
experimentation and it is something nord
conceptual idirect ed ex ample sing the
history of finance are for instance
relate to a  mpere that built tram
complicated da artifact to reach surrender alt
but without the kind of planning est o
manipolati madaction is
this kind of reasoning tua hypotesis
think thanks to thanks to the kind of
brandon manipulation of objects rendo
mani pure sono artifact to arrive
tempati veli tue  risate you see that the
expression thinking during his expresses
di sfax construens his name of this kind
ovart i fans that was given by and
reserch e david booting that was
starling this kind of weekend con sam
experimentation ok because it is e
manipoli sono bob gent.  ma disease blasi
cali relate to discover not for instance
to confirm e fiori as usual
experimentation place di troll il menis
ryan sei ai otto aygo sable tutu i think i
play off models are distribute than
ever abstract of course models are
abstract bataille or ideal bataille
contende that  the arab strap ed ai deal
on line and pickwick jan sense di cosa
irreality models are always con creed
object of various keyne  s even if you di
even if you use e mathematics and watercress
disease e concrete object that is
written i teaser staff and it is not
only gli now of course it is also ninì
now but it is external eyes and
refined
in defense mathematics this is absolutely
parte models are distributie del never
astra ai fink model si santifica
reasoning are niedermair fiction si paul
surrogates orme believe all those
age labels i told you they were not present
certain twenty years and go nord they are
a problematica ideals sections in
particular model sardisti  beat n ever
after models are always distributor
material cities for instance con chris
diagram physics del computational models
and other things models for example
mathematics mental modders widget and
are in pip particular henri pitt ball
and ever changing configuration and
transformation of neural networks and
chemical distribution  and the level of
human brains arcon great to because
there santin physical and not only
f  isica l'orso belonging to end organisms
dehar concretes even if interno pence
models are abstract ondine pickwick
yalcin sadat il mental notes share datum
differences extensa to buy cruz or
scientist depending on the title
l'impresa new beaters take ai contenta
tu somm rais that the  so called
abstract model you will we usuali 6
this is a nostra moto can be better
describe in terms of moscow what nel
sesia e chandra 6 caranna in risse
article col manifest model it is no del
death is war pursuit andres the problems
and concept researchers art  fest with it
is also an internal model peak view that
in the external models that is of course
of the council that is present internal of
and it is manifest mycosis t shirt end
to the house group members to perform mani
pulisce da for common while
presentation of the proposed concept  del
manifesto model bear in prof group
dynamics su you can ore di see that it
is very difficult to imagine that e
fiction en fiction a liszt hughes
fic  tion basica league senso literary
fiction
it is difficult to imagine that anna
karenina il fi e motel similar to the
model that are working in science to go
is of course dell'interno representation
presence slight differences in dual
brand andrè first ue unique moder that
is the  manifest model e zamble con fritz
external of course per te shaun to this
fall that in science the rise quarti the
opposite model front of other spetti luce
so it is also impossible iii in
l aper consists china computational
counterpart you say this artù con chris
model be  7b stand up light dinner
neural i genera i Laboratories bear in di
scales high and the king venter of this
ethnographic dei con ethnographic
reaserch inserti fi club med diners s
and chandrasekar su models are so tu sei
just model that i'm the life and has
made his la sua start biztree click
criticizing the light of this recent
epistemological con fip vincerà chun
essere late to specie all kinds of
epistemica actions  abstract nesun from
ideals ti kenobi soleri relate to e
pirica lina de classi del to and or to
the theoretical lincoln monthly state cure
diesel thief of scientific enterprise
high stakes plain this passages of
course week and say that models are
ideal extra bat vera ideals hann
abstract ness il club when you have
estati cloud certificates reprise for
enterprise for instance in sé textbook
but when you see models at work in the
dynamics
tifi discovery se deve anti
fick abducted processes it is not easy to see
this extract ness ideal ti because you
can  not con perdit model with final
target system because the final
target systems il in many che snow che
hai la ball it is just be thanks to
the work of the model exactly easing
case of the thought experiment kind of
water o sotto the experiment me by
galileo  concerning the falling bodies
des rois of the aristotle physics so that
works in dell'iphone models in science
there is something that is called common
cl  othing and the tisane
manipulative stilt football picos common coding
aipo the size of death di execution
perception and imagination of gods of
women's share e common 3 presentation
that is indeed coating in the brain di
scott è in vizza to anyone office 36
perception of external moving automatically
li trigger in the other to imagination
and execution of common coding garanti
is the integration of tuili internal and
external models because it is imported
in my opinion total in porta andujar
speaking of santifichi model si sa tv
discovery discovery processes to
remember that there is discontinuous
l  'interplay between the external modest
che b mani clean e modify end e interna
representation of it and this inter
place and grant results that we are
looking for the external model x tour
dei terminal one in unpredictable web
providing di lecce for change ok
sui ufo you  find some information out of
paws some insight some suggestion in
the model microsoft's fletcher al  l the
model is known necessary internal there o ryu
ken find internal lisanti news news mind
thanks to the fact that you are
reinternalize mother sue chance for
change of the name of innovative and
internal to the model new brand area exchanges
activated created new connection with
tinto alcan  motif for fair
manipulation sadr e vision of the
external boc models are proposals
m.pros in in what a fool ico con tilt aspects
in week end a hughes and expression kong
by sciandra 6 canal people sisters and
environment ha la forma si dull goethe
in un  integrate di fashion show this is
my image home of the role of models at
least known all models bard no del tar
work lui in santifica discovery
processing standard di extension between
highbury session andar strazio is dead
in india idealizes shaun you have
something falls with respect to  the
target bat in this case we ever we
already arde Late qui sawyer absolutely
able to see things get the man with his
not true it is not l'org  anic me
and so there are some for cities diaisi
shaun and with respect to target si
spende seri deaf a vela e la dolce in
scientific prof discovery profit end di
adire zampe o vapps traction it is
enough traction diagram use by maxwell
in his reserch about madness  isan end è
na straccioni selway completely
different from the potential horror e
via vai labor target system without
special problem also nord necessary
similar I think this is the ideal venax
thrust mode and this point
we have to move power mai presentation
again street journal is because you
imagine aido not like fiction alisa aid
1 trike della dda that scientific models
are fiction that is the heart like they
have the same ontologica al status of
anna karina ok su first of all
am not war ride by deontologica status
model because of modern because ai to
you i'm not free canto
sohaib not think this is the road to the
philosopher that are presenze that the
new man is now apple su wii che non li
of the phenomenon it is not the project
formi the problem of the ontological
status os models but are no del sun
realistic because you see dei sei ma
adversaries beuys model models are
abstract soder different from the target
system mar member the title di hoover
sometimes target systems  are not get no
un tour in the discovery prosthesis in
vitro network bronze sculptures ma
workers orte lobacevske jan uk livia
diagram are just the opposite o venier
fiction o dove genera mac believe inter
play off air one believe belong to you
man px il many situation  house of every
day light is not e special character
world water day amin steve more or less
mimetic betis simile in some cases berno
similar verde were not be it because
there similarities with some other
aspect and possible creative external
mode mode switch a respect to provider e
aiab all information about the target
system jms discovering sun new
representations la bowden euros
interface da balde più con se tu
geometri did not offer in the second day
aristide regulatory tools stabilize
insam exterior form and cai duty live
still note intention ali establish ad
es fiction life like romance writers
food intention alibi assessing the
karate character of harry potter ora la
career anna carrieri but is the usual
of  san pawl ove fictions opposite in do
min and tis margaret morrison 6 and ai
agree with her also the rise temptation
to category eni tra hip hop a
realistic representation
and se fiction aiea hardware that this
would be and mixed between the seas the leaf
before rivals because  this way
of usa category from realistic
presentation third very little about the
road toast representation play in
producing knowledge di zampone thai
che view weekly about her and search of nel
fashion and chandra Secca demonstrated set
margaret morris margaret morrison is a
right this is another famous  kind of
mother botnet reanimated the end in this is
live it is good to show the springer
handbo  ok of modern est science dead eye
and by ted uil and collaborator now by
tommaso bertolotti betis and yuji book of
any kind of brothers
it is about to one thousand friandre
pages versus the fact that it is
difficult to render and times of somma
rasi summa rising  ai viaoffered freak
models in philosophical the article in le
journal because there are many models
and to many functions sunday in top
model so it is not easy to deal with
models di slow ski are some dica the sun
deck ad ago
now is less trial  because the hero of
fiction a liszt make.believe people
in short il morite restu produsse lotto
parti corse lotus publication that say
this is the licks kind of fiction
this is another desire ad es aspect took
over some mai nord on
l'ocaitudine models bethany whale  and
are not able to cover wide range of
model
the problem of modern and fall sapsan
forza assumptions are consider e such
only seen him the light of steel tubino
un target  si sta ai un income di
credo from javier force online and post hoc
analysis bagarre perfetti through in the
model itself begins relative autonomy
during smart yuri stick cognitive
con fip prof.re arte tweets exploitation
su not always models are chosen with
consciousness with  our ness or the fact
that they presenze sap sachs berardi
skies of brothers maderno there not only
kinds of water is that are used in
scientific cognition in santilli cogniti
the next film
margaret morrison help us countries this
knot s logical proprio noterai viktro
concluded from force premises  badr
haber e nepi stemmi quande deals with
the way maybe presentation transmits
information
about con crysis to say that fictional
models are important sips sonole
doris orbison and then only in
enduro races but the presentation so now we have
this slide 3 pisa relate to to the
problem of hanfa sizing del fact the
time dealing with creative processes
enzo is the software it is important
distinction  di twin static and dynamic
aspect and then the concept of epistéme
workwear epistéme warfare mix that we
che news in the peace telling warfare
refers to the fact that you can use in
science fiction in due note fictions
imagination bat fiction and fall citizen
propaganda bat fiction a  liszt say we
use fiction news fiction in the sense of
fiction and imagination but you can use
bear falsi teese propaganda basei to not
play.me piste micron i so-called
distinguish between e piste week end non
epistemico roll
feierabend d'escrime all the ways
galileo used  to convinse people and
grease thotel ians
e io so useful for experimental and
many many other time of propaganda and
perhaps su ebi sport dai fake weekend era
you because there are some a the other
art aspect haiku d'escrime about my
struggle e gates fiction alisa  for
instance aias models are not use and
intend è fiction and we have also to
conclude this is the last light that
when we use the word credi paul credi
ball world mac believe enzo dei corso
good in epistemological line culture area
invester dei change theoretical li confused
bat ai biological di klina because he the
sinni water week end with the military
framework of academic struggle between
disciplines dominate dai e pattern
proliferation certificates vitis that
just producer  3d bowl o surrogates
models looking aggressive there maybe anti
physicists weiwei current are the best
fragments of death philosophers this means
that there are some part of the so
called scientific disciplines for
instance psycology in economics when
there are just molex but not necessary
ii the final satis  factors knowledge and
with celtics
tractors forint for instance
explanations or predictive capacities
nancy cartwright world about this
problem
e se fino capacities ben no credi paul
world
ok lo genzero il beer room for many
passion and suffered qualification it is
now ten o'clock are here in  europe in
italy so high thing that ai spent the
time the  time that was my di sposa
and this is the book about al dap tic
gleision of town i'm where there is also
the problem of model x striscioni
d'escrime this is the book of two
thousand seven team steel about the
suitable straccio rosette di  creativity e
book and rosso e si ries
ebook series studies in up live philosophers
epistemologists brush nord ethics beta and
director at springer this is then arti
con english ai explained this problem of
the scientific modern inter twine with
problem of fiction su thank you for your
attention  also in short ok maria to see
my last light o no no no talas tutor
athens way you were not particulars lesse
seri because they were you you were you
were able to listen my boy sensory wells
en internet project
sotto choc i miss you call center for
light  brix di lorenzo eumo you said
if it is possible to generale is the new
repeat the question of morus moro no no
no ai fix it is not possible absolutely
because there are too many canzo models
every kind of generals station is done
to be kind of assaliti you can't in
steve mac and kind of analysis of some
kind of brothers to detect out the works
are the work and di exchange su userful
of close you can see the next groff
model  cindy spaces and the cognitive
tracks mo logical reserch e cambi also
userful because
for instance is able to help to improve
the english model the model present
presence on the opa cities
ok the sun kinds of race for instance la
bohème biochemical laboratories sud dei
generals station heaslip possible  but it
is possible the analysis of particular
casa mia
ex coach guido phenomena been mahroug
ana action series and morus last i
file correct studio is that there is
always the problem of building and
modern jazz inteso scientific processes
and to reach and particular sachs and
particular target  su the fact that tune
label di urla betis kind of model s
fiction is not acceptable because you
are not usic inside santificati vite del
no dell  e fiction you are using the water
e something that present characters
that are completely true that you
think you expect were able to leave you
to riches heures
il professor mariani conversation with
you a lucky experimentation ok corso in
this case derise problem relate to the
impossibility  of general easing this
kind of the part of the scientist of the
model but we can work and in
epistemologia conti texans ai thing that
we can have some starting point bet
relate to the possibility of rendering
sotto 6 en eco cognitive iron man
that is good for  a discovery so this
this means that not only you are two
count on people that have to say
goodnight
but also and with the film iron man settis
particulars in crime touche spa dr
discover ability ok ending
last weekend cyber war censis to
choose the good model  to go equity
research and from this point of view ai
think that some parts of the recent
scientific research i seeds in parte
jeopardy icefrog di strai  ght or you so
there is not the sam wood e cognitive
nvgh iron man the fall of human creativi
tia newman discover ability sono
possibility of shoes i futuristi xbl
models to get midro search pad of course
it is difficult to to build calle kind
of milta disco  about prog
overcoming oneself going back to back for moro è
ok so so of the philosophical front
il punto violenta dorso from semiotico
point of view the model year e kind of
semiotica e semiotica object because i
can b and away with high cronica aspect
with proposition all '  aspect sum any
kind of science icons indices end e in
dissenso weekend isili consider the
model santifichi mote la semiotica set
ma of course and special semiotica
object of death ax in science disease
and persian front point of view bator
show so you know you can you can  easley
is already spa bliss is performed for the bay
ne if you remember inter
there was e slide in which ai set
inference does not be in rome e con i
fix science spero con i texans
perspective does not have to be seen
only the kind of mathematics and logic
core in france mag
using natural language bar  a torso using
general
science and science of africa is ok
the original so the paradise shift the
passage of one from e paradise for
east by new tonia mechanix studer the tv
sticks mechanix for instance tood
restrict relativity 8 degenerate the tv
on a belongs to the  so called post
positivista tradition retis the one that
has started by karl popper dei a un
inter ester different with respect to
the neopositivista to the dynamics of
science
I think with isa interest to the fact that
one of the most important
aspekte weekend e epocali characters fiom no  del
science is its dynamics not only the
structure of this is it was defenseless beo
positivity but also cool and also
lakatos betis del follower over
popper 6 jun not be wi  th problem celtic
discovery because like in inter
nineteenth century dei steel without tv
discovery generation at the moment times
discovery burke sonean intuition
il canton guest alt switch but now
fortunate league
we have more about mechanism xcover not
only texture all philosophers anthony the
hills aias but also text  artificial
intelligence because we have r.off
machine learning machines discovery that
was able to build many program senso
rational rational tools that are able to
mime senti film discovery starting from
the hole del discovery of herbert simon
this fantastic help us connecting
with the fantastic top james  jones
mr nice dinner need ouch ouch ouch ouch
has suffered tight tenchio pria thank you
for the people said guerra attende in
the conference press lecture tomorrow
ivi we will have more time to speak
too paribas ibri a 6